if the shadow figure contains valuable
rival forces they ought to be
assimilated into actual experience and
not repressed it is up to the ego to
give up its pride and priggishness and
to live out something that seems to be
dark but actually may not be this can
require a sacrifice just as heroic as
the conquest of passion but in an
opposite sense the ethical difficulties
that arise when one meets one shadow are
well described in the 18th book of the
Quran in this tale Moses meets hideth
the green one or first angel of God in
the desert they wander along together
and hither expresses his fear that Moses
will not be able to witness his deeds
without indignation if Moses cannot bear
with him and trust him he that will have
to leave presently he that scuttles the
fishing boat of some poor villagers then
before Moses his eyes he kills a
handsome young man and finally he
restores the fallen wall of a city of
unbelievers Moses cannot help expressing
his indignation and so Hitler has to
leave him before his departure however
he explains the reasons for his actions
by scuttling the boat he actually saved
it for its owners because pirates were
on their way to steal it as it is the
fishermen can salvage it the handsome
young man was on his way to commit a
crime and by killing him hid that are
saved his pious parents from infamy by
restoring the wall to pious young men
were saved from ruin because their
treasure was buried under it Moses who
had been so morally indignant saw now
too late that his judgment had been too
hasty Heather's doings had seemed to be
totally evil but in fact they were not
looking at this story naively one might
assume that Heather is the lawless
capricious evil shadow of pious law
abiding Moses but this is not the case
Heather is much more the personification
of some secret creative actions of the
Godhead one can find a similar meaning
in the famous Indian story of the king
and the corpse as interpreted by Henry
Zimmer it is no accident that I have not
quoted a dream to illustrate this subtle
problem I have chosen this well-known
story from the Quran because it sums up
the experience of a lifetime which would
very rarely be expressed with such
clarity in an individual dream when dark
figures turn up in our dreams and seem
to want something we cannot be sure
whether they personify merely a shadowy
part of ourselves or the self or both at
the same time divining in advance where
there are dark partner symbolizes a
shortcoming that we should overcome or a
meaningful bit of life that we should
accept this is one of the most difficult
problems that we encounter on the way to
individuation
moreover the dream symbols are often so
subtle and complicated that one cannot
be sure of their interpretation in such
a situation all one can do is accept the
discomfort of ethical doubt making no
final decisions or commitments and
continuing to watch the dreams this
resembles the situation of Cinderella
when her stepmother threw a heap of good
and bad pees in front of her and asked
her to sort them out although it seemed
quite hopeless Cinderella began
patiently to sort the peas and suddenly
doves or ants in some versions came to
help her
these creatures symbolize helpful deeply
unconscious impulses that can only be
felt in one's body as it were and that
point to a way out somewhere right at
the bottom of one's own being one
generally does know where one should go
and what one should do but there are
times when the clown we call I behaves
in such a distracting fashion that the
inner voice cannot make its presence
felt
sometimes all attempts to understand the
hints of the unconscious fail and in
such a difficulty one can only have the
courage to do what seems to be right
while being ready to change course if
the suggestions of the unconscious
should suddenly point in another
direction it may also happen although
this is unusual that a person will find
it better to resist the urge of the
unconscious even at the price of feeling
worked by doing so rather than depart
too far from the state of being
this would be the situation of people
who had to live out a criminal
disposition in order to be completely
themselves the strength and inner
clarity needed by the ego in order to
make such a decision stem secretly from
the great man who apparently does not
want to reveal himself too clearly it
may be that the self wants the ego to
make a free choice or it may be that the
self depends on human consciousness and
its decisions to help him to become
manifest when it comes to such difficult
ethical problems no one can truly judge
the deeds of others each man has to look
to his own problem and try to determine
what is right for himself as an old Zen
Buddhist master said we must follow the
example of the cowherd who watches his
ox with a stick so that it will not
graze on other people's meadows these
new discoveries of depth psychology are
bound to make some change in our
collective ethical views for they will
compel us to judge all human actions in
a much more individual and subtle way
the discovery of the unconscious is one
of the most far-reaching discoveries of
recent times but the fact that
recognition of its unconscious reality
involves honest self-examination and
reorganization of one's life causes many
people to continue to behave as if
nothing at all has happened it takes a
lot of courage to take the unconscious
seriously and to tackle the problems at
races most people are too indolent to
think deeply about even those moral
aspects of their behavior of which they
are conscious they are certainly too
lazy to consider how the unconscious
affects them